hi everyone this video is all about how
the information in an organism's genes
is expressed as its traits this occurs
through the action of molecules called
proteins
but before we get into the details let's
start with the basics what are traits
well traits are in organism's observable
characteristics and there are some
really weird but really cool traits out
there in the animal kingdom spiders for
example can make seven different types
of silk elephants have an amazingly low
risk of developing cancer and some
jellyfish have the ability to Glow
that's right the crystal jelly can
bioluminesce or glow in the dark all on
its own so now let's dive into the
details of how these traits are
expressed specifically let's look at the
jellyfish trait of bioluminescence
we know that an organism's traits are
affected by its genes so let's travel
into the nucleus of the crystal jelly
cells to where its genes are found on
chromosomes a chromosome shown here is a
cell structure that contains a coiled up
DNA molecule I personally like to think
of chromosomes as the packaged and
organized version of DNA a DNA molecule
is made up of subunits called
nucleotides nucleotides are often called
A T C and G which stand for adenine
thymine cytosine and guanine a gene is a
specific stretch or a chunk of
nucleotides within a DNA molecule
so a chromosome and its DNA are like a
cookbook that contains recipes for
making an organism genes are the recipes
and just like how letters are arranged
in a specific order to form words in a
recipe the nucleotides in a gene are
also arranged in a specific order to
convey information
so what does the cell make with these
Gene recipes
the cell uses the information in genes
to make other molecules called proteins
so our Crystal jelly must have jeans on
its chromosomes that are responsible for
its trait of bioluminescence because of
work done by scientists we now know that
the jellyfish is bioluminescence
involves one gene in particular the
coding sequence of this Gene is made up
of roughly 700 nucleotides all arranged
in a specific order and this Gene acts
like a recipe for making a protein
called Green fluorescent protein or gfp
for short whenever you hear the word
fluorescent just think glowy gfp is a
glowy protein that can emit green light
and it's this presence of gfp in the
jellyfish's cells that allows the
jellyfish to bioluminesce but proteins
can do so much more than glow there are
thousands of tasks that different
proteins carry out in order for cells to
function
some proteins help provide structure
some help move substances into and out
of the cell and others help carry out
chemical reactions all proteins are made
up of subunits called amino acids which
are connected in a chain it's the order
of nucleotides in a gene that determines
the order of amino acids in a protein
and the Order of amino acids is
important because it determines the 3D
shape that the protein will take on and
a protein's shape in turn affects its
function for the gfp protein this
protein has a special sequence of three
amino acids that end up in the middle of
a barrel-like structure when the protein
takes on its 3D shape these amino acids
form the part of the protein that can
fluoresce they can absorb energy and
then emit that energy as green light
so to sum it all up genes affect traits
through the actions of the proteins that
they encode the order of nucleotides in
a gene determines the order of amino
acids in a protein and a protein's amino
acids determines its structure and its
function
the crystal jelly is bioluminescence and
the discovery of gfp highlight why this
knowledge is so important scientists
have used the gfp Gene and protein to
make countless discoveries now
researchers can attach dfp to other
things such as other proteins or viruses
making them visible through
bioluminescence and easy to track gfp
has made the invisible visible and it's
allowed researchers to learn how neurons
develop and how cancer cells spread and
all of this research started with
wondering about a single trait observed
in the crystal jelly similarly
scientists are studying the properties
of spider silk proteins in order to make
new biocompatible materials and they're
also studying elephants for clues about
how to prevent cancer in humans what
animals do you think will lead to the
next big discovery